mothers music is highly strong extremely
loud or soft full of strong emotions
fantastic contrasts it is as he lived in
a state of continuous excitement it is
highly unusual for anyone to compose
music which transmits this level of
agitation the average genius allow me to
say average genius even if he is nervous
wide overexcited in real life like
Beethoven for example finds a way to
control language and form indeed
mother's work is masterful and perfect
on the one hand there are no mistakes
where harmony counterpoint or any other
compositional skill are concerned and
this high degree of perfection clearly
shows us a genius at work on the other
hand however no attempt is made here to
tame the occasional shapeless flow of
weird and unpredictable ideas mal are
composed for following his inspiration
as if the music were dictated to him he
turned his state of excitement and his
arsenal of memories into music
translating this intensity and this vast
collection of fragmented impressions
into a musical language so that it can
be shared with others is the essence of
Mahler's art I use the word translate
following Spinoza's thoughts in his
tractor to stay logical politicals where
he mentions that
Hebrew world Navi means both translator
and profit was Mallory prophet he was
certainly a seer who could sense future
events mother died in 1911 in the den
still peaceful Habsburg Empire he would
never get to read Spengler's in taganga
Ivan Landess which was published seven
years later he didn't live to see the
horrors of the two world wars he didn't
live to experience the Holocaust yet one
cannot escape the feeling that in his
music we hear a foreboding a vision of
these terrible future events the funeral
marches in the second fifth and sixth
symphonies the frequent appearance of
military fanfares
the young soldier who is mesmerised by
the gallows the heartbreakingly hopeless
march in the sleet from the air these
seem like musical descriptions of later
tragedies we hear soldiers marching in
heavy boots and we hear the pain of the
hunted tortured victims mothers music is
an uninhibited outpouring of of his own
psyche but malar was no over sentimental
adolescent who wanted to share his
misery with the world he could see
terrible things coming living in Carroll
Lugar's
Vienna with his fine perceptive instinct
he must have felt the roots of tensions
that led to the assassination in
Sarajevo and to the emergence of Hitler
as Leonard Bernstein observed in his
essay about Mahler and I quote from
birth time the music is almost cruel in
his revelations it is like a camera that
has caught Western society in the moment
of its incipient
decay only after we have experienced all
this through the smoking ovens of
Auschwitz the frenetically bombed
jungles of Vietnam and here follows
Bernstein's long long list of tragic and
inhuman events of the 20th century only
after all this he continues can we
finally listen to Mahler's music and
understand that it foretold all there is
nothing mystical about this there were
others who sensed the end of the world
the Letson targeter mensch height as
Karl Kraus expressed it a few years
later but the greatest prophet in
fantasy occur Vienna who composed the
funeral music for the 20th century more
convincingly than anybody else was
Gustav Mahler